a highly anticipated announcement from
Apple today could offer a new way to get
your news and entertainment Apple is
expected to unveil its own streaming
service putting it in direct competition
with companies like Netflix and Amazon
stars like Oprah Winfrey Reese
Witherspoon and Jennifer Aniston are
already signed up to provide original
content along with directors Steven
Spielberg and JJ Abrams Jamie yuccas is
at Apple's Steve Jobs theater in
Cupertino California Jamie good morning
good morning at least some of those
celebrities are expected to be here for
that announcement Apple has spent a
billion dollars to produce at least 25
new shows the question now is with so
many streaming services already out
there is it too little too late right
now if you want to watch Jennifer
Aniston acting alongside Reese
Witherspoon you can go to Netflix and
queue up an episode of friends but soon
you'll reportedly be able to see the two
co-starring in their own series via a
less than friendly rival streaming
service from Apple teasing Monday's
announcement with an invitation that
simply says it's Showtime Apple is
pitting itself against not just Netflix
but other well-established streaming
services like Amazon and Hulu tech
analyst Wang neuen can they catch up oh
that is the million dollar question it's
really a billion dollar question right I
don't think they've ever been about
being first out the gate indeed Apple
music launched almost seven years after
Spotify but quickly became a major
competitor helped by the fact it was
pre-installed on millions of iPhones
analysts say that same handheld foothold
could help the company's streaming
service as well
Avel enters the content race at a time
when Netflix is reportedly spending as
much as fifteen billion dollars this
year on original programming like
stranger things with more than a hundred
and thirty nine million global
subscribers while Apple spending so far
is closer to just one billion it has
more than 1.4 billion devices in use
around the world each one of those
owners is a potential customer with
Apple's recent smartphone sales coming
in lower than expected analysts say the
company's launch into content is in line
with changing consumer demands people's
tolerances for spending on Hardware on
boxes I think reach a certain limit but
services the content immediate that's
what I really want to pay for it's what
I want when I want it how I want it
there are reports Apple might offer its
original programming for free up front
to lure customers into buying a package
that includes established subscription
services like HBO our Stars we also
expect to hear about a streaming news
service as well we'll know more though
at 1:00 p.m. Eastern Time
10:00 a.m. Pacific viana oh I can't wait
I'm not betting against Apple ever I
mean they always say we can reach a
billion people in the pockets worldwide
because it's right here on our telephone
have a billion users
yes owned billion dollar investment big
exciting day over there Showtime